[Musique]
on vous voit presque pas mais je savais
que ça allait être impressionnant alors
c'est pas vous soyez 400 qui est
impressionnant ni même les quelques
milliers qui vont me regarder à la télé
non c'est plutôt masque il m'épate
vous n'avez peut-être pas conscience
mais que c'est que vous êtes 400 gens à
venir et vous êtes consentant à l'avance
vous savez pas de quoi je vais vous
parler vous êtes consentant une somme
mois voilà bravo merci pour votre
confiance
c'est pas vraiment ce site a donc alors
on va commencer l'expérience la question
apporte bonheur
j'ai un sujet très sérieux à vous
communiquer à vous partager c'est un
élan extraordinaire de ma vie mais je
voudrais avant de passer dans des excès
des explications un peu complexe
économique
ah non vous n'avez rien vu
donc avant de vous dire de quoi je vais
vous parler je voudrais vous faire vivre
une petite expérience est là pour ça je
vais vous demander de vous concentrer
d'abord asseyez-vous oui je sais que
vous êtes déjà si je ne suis pas que
blonde mais je vous demande de vous
asseoir confortablement consciemment et
ben voilà là ça gigote déjà déjà voyez
vous n'êtes pas de base est là bas on a
entendu des cris tout à l'heure donc
vous êtes si c'est bon tout le monde est
concentré vous aussi derrière vos écrans
je vous vois je vous vois alors je vais
faire appel à votre concentration sur
vos sensations vos émotions votre
imagination je vous demande de mettre
votre petit raison d'une lime et qu'est
ce qu'elle nous fait celle-là il ya une
caisse qui devrait passer
j'adore ma raison quelquefois il est
très utile mais quelquefois juste voilà
elle adore que je la gratouille ici il
faut la calmer un petit peu donc voila
vous fait un câlin à vous pensez à votre
mental ou le ranger un petit peu et là
vous allez fermer les yeux s'il vous
plaît vous fermez les yeux et vous
imaginez imaginer qu'à partir du mois
prochain vous recevez sur votre compte
en banque
suffisamment pour vivre une fois deux
fois le mois suivant ça se répète et ça
jusqu'à la fin de votre vie
il ya rien à faire ça tombe tout cuit
si vous bossez c'est en plus et
cumulables et c'est pas seulement vous
mais vos proches aussi alors attention
question qu'est ce que ça change pour
vous avec ce revenu de base qu'est ce
que ça va changer au niveau du travail
la famille du temps libéré peut-être
pouvoir d'achat supplémentaire
je vous laisse explorer un petit peu
goûté le
manger je suis obligé de vous
interrompre parce qu'on est un peu
chronométrés je vais vous demander de
revenir parmi nous et voilà alors j'ai
observé un petit peu des réactions j'ai
vu des grands soupirs
je pense que là il ya dépensé peut-être
qu'ils vous sont venues du type à voir
la fin de mois ça ça va être plus cola
et la fin de vie aussi peut-être
il vit et comme les enfants là aussi
après tout les milieux de ma vie sera
sous le certainement soulagé je vais pas
devoir bosser tout le temps pour
économiser pour les sécuriser post
mortem
j'ai peut-être pouvoir les voir grandir
donc ça c'est un premier élan qui peut
vous venir et et oui le revenu de base
est censé permettez moi une fois le jeu
nouveau débile combler les besoins de
base
jusque là ça va d'ailleurs ça tombe bien
parce que l'article 25 de la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen et
la citoyenne site 4 besoin il commence
comme ça toute personne a droit à un
niveau de vie suffisant
déjà là en préco s'arrêtait mais il cite
ces quatre besoin l' alimentation santé
habillement logement et après il
enchaîne sur pour être sécurisés en cas
de maladie de maternité de vieillesse
cherchez l'intrus et c'est donc
finalement c'est déjà un droit il reste
plus qu'à avoir les moyens de ce droit
ça nous apporte un profond sentiment de
sécurité sécurité matérielle bien sûr
c'est la définition mais aussi sécurité
psychologique
aujourd'hui vous connaissez certainement
vous connaissez certainement des gens
qui travaillent et qui pourtant qu une
messe le sentiment la peur de la
précarité est après la sécurité ya les
sourires ses oies mais tout est possible
en fait c'est la liberté tous les
projets que j'ai dû laisser tomber
avec le temps libre par rapport au
travail tout ce qui a pu vous venir la
liberté et la créativité entreprendre
sécurisé être artiste sécurisé inventé
sécurisé faire des tedx
sécuriser cet extraordinaire après la
liberté vient le sens parce que vos
choix vous les ferez en cohérence avec
vos valeurs avec votre rythme aussi au
fil de la vie au fil de la semaine au
fil du mois vous pourrez vous vous
pourrez gérer tout ça et gagner en
confiance en soi ce qui va avec la
confiance aux autres et aux serristes
c'est rigolo parce que c'est réciproque
c'est un cercle vertueux et c'est
contagieux donc la confiance et sur une
base d'égalité et de justice puisque
tout le monde là à la naissance vous
naissez vous êtes reconnu comme un
individu un être humain avec des besoins
et ses besoins sont pris en charge par
la société à laquelle vous participez ça
tombe bien c'est bien fait et tout ça se
conclut sur le besoin de paix qu'on a
tous au fond nous aussi différents que
nous soyons m'a parlé de bonheur tout à
leur besoin de paix intérieure
individuelle et besoin de paix
collective sociale
on ouvre là un champ énorme sur un
nouveau contrat social rapidement tous
les besoins j'espère que vous les avoir
fait un petit peu goûté parce que
c'était pour moi le plus important je
pourrais m'arrêter là sauf que et il ya
cette petite voix que j'imagine vous
avez aussi qui vous dis moi c'est bien
beau de rêver mais maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait ça y est on les a alléché
on va pas les laisser comme ça quand
même la frustration c'est mauvais pour
la santé
c'est l'âge où vous c'est compliqué hein
donc on va lui répondre je vais tout
vous dire j'ai tout vous dire ou presque
20 tous qui rentrera dans 18 minutes hop
le revenu base c'est quoi c'est une idée
un concept avec plein de concrétisation
différentes dans tous les sens avec des
projets de société des leviers de
financement plein de différence là je
vais revenir aux fondamentaux
à la base la définition le revenu de
base est individuel il est
inconditionnel vous travaillez vous
travaillez pas vous l'avez il est
cumulable
je le dis avec tous types de revenus il
est inaliénable on ne pourra jamais vous
l'enlevez d'ailleurs il est pas
imposables forcément sinon ça marche pas
et il est universel alors
on va commencer par des expérimentations
mais l'ambition est universelle et c'est
important
une fois qu'on a vu cette définition là
maintenant vous savez de quoi je parle
on peut parler sur des bases communes
sommes alors à cette petite voix qui va
vous parler
il ya trois types d'objection est trop
petit d'objection c'est ça peut être par
exemple
ah non mais ça va pas du tout non non
non non non pas d'accord pas d'accord il
ya un mode la définition qui me fait
bugger qui me bloque c'est pas possible
un conditionnel par exemple on va pas
donner de l'argent rien faire rigoler
bon ça se fait déjà on a un filet social
en france quand même heureusement mais
voilà il peut y avoir des blocages comme
ça qu'on va appeler la valeur travail
etc
il ya des réponses possibles on pourrait
en discuter des heures je suis prête
mais j'ai pas le temps donc très
rapidement quand je garde mon enfant où
je le fais garder c'est quand la
différence d'un côté c'est rémunéré
l'autre non pourtant la vertu sociale
est la même ce qui a pas des métiers qui
peuvent être inutiles voire nuisibles à
l'environnement notre santé etc
donc est-ce que la rémunération c'est
une reconnaissance de l'utilité sociale
pas forcément après il ya la question de
la productivité la productivité qui
explose et qui devrait nous libérer du
temps les machines les logiciels ça sert
à quoi si ce n'est libéré l'homme et la
femme du travail
alors on pourrait partager ce temps
libéré les bénéfices aussi d'ailleurs et
on le fait pas donc voilà il ya ce type
de réponse je peux pas entrer dans
chaque mot ou dans chaque contre
arguments qui peuvent venir
je vous laisserai le loisir de les
étudier plus tard la 2e 2e type
d'objection alors c'est oui mais
attention parce que si on installe un
revenu de base
ils risquent d'arriver par un truc des
dérives c'est vrai c'est vrai alors
d'abord bravo bravo parce que tu as
réussi à passer de la première étape
c'est l'utopie est roi c'est une utopie
c'est pas possible on jette à la
poubelle on regarde même pas là il ya
quand même un oui vous avez vu ça
commence par oui bon il ya un mais
d'accord mais c'est un mec et
constructif ici et dire que si par
exemple vous dites avec un revenu une
base mais
mais il risque d'y avoir la hausse des
prix ou la baisse des salaires oui
possible
pas très bien on prend ça rend compte et
puis on se dit qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire pour éviter ça on peut mettre en
place à l telle mesure qu'on va ajouter
orgue base pour en faire un projet de
société
finalement un revenu de base c'est quoi
c'est un outil et ça dépend comment on
va l'utiliser dans quelle intention
le dernier type de d'arguments c'est le
oui mais comment en grande angoisse
aussi alors la double filiation
non seulement vous êtes passés au dessus
du taux pis en plus vous avez réussi à
surmonter les peurs en les transformant
en moteur on l'a vu tout à l'heure
et donc on arrive à la faisabilité
on arrive à déjà les premières
réflexions de transition nos politiques
sont à ce niveau là nous pas encore y
est en grand les rejoignent parce qu'ils
ont un peu besoin de nous pour les
guider donc après les contre arguments
je vais répondre quand même parce que je
la connais ça trésor là et j'en ai
entendu c'est toujours la même la
première qui est rien oui mais comment
mais comment ça se finance
où est ce qu'on va trouver l'argent on
est bien conditionner quand même ce que
chaque bonne idée on la conditionne
d'avant son financement alors que ça
pourrait être le contraire mais c'est
pas grave c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave je lui répondre ça va calmer up
la première chose c'est d'abord qu'il ya
plein de financement plein il ya plein
de recherche partout alors imaginons ah
les braves gens c'est ma dernière offre
ma dernière offre 2000 euros par mois
pour tout le monde
allez dépêchez vous d'en profiter parce
que ça sera pas pour tout le monde ne
sera pas tout le temps etc
et alors là vous voyez l'astérix et nous
privatisant tous les services publics la
sécu les retraites c'est un pas bon donc
méfiez vous il ya des régressions
sociales qui se cachent parmi les
revenus bad un revenu de base n'est pas
fait pour faire des économies
un revenu de base c'est une avancée
sociétale du même ordre que le droit de
vote universel ou alors la sécu elle
même
ou le droit au logement etc les
premières versions qu'on pourra soutenir
c'est celle qui sont de
l'autofinancement c'est à dire on
imagine on prend toutes les aides que
l'état donne déjà on le met dans un
grand sac
et puis on le découpe et on les répartit
tout le monde a la même chose on arrive
à des montants de à peu près 500 euros
je parle en france par personne et par
mois
c'est le montant des minima sociaux
objectif simplifier la redistribution
par l'état donc on rationalise un petit
peu les différents services et cetera on
simplifie aussi pour ceux qui le
reçoivent
parce que donner des remplir des
dossiers c'est souvent humiliant il ya
une sacrée stigmatisation qu'on minimise
souvent on touche pas trop aux
inégalités sociales mais on enlève la
grande pauvreté parce qu'au moins notre
filet de protection n'a plus de trous
savez les 18 25 le premier enfant par
rapport au deuxième et c'est en
acceptant donc ça c'est le premier
levier après tous les autres leviers
vont avoir vous allez le voir pour
ambition d'atteindre de plus en plus le
seuil de pauvreté qui en france avoisine
les 1000 euros
on essaye d'arriver à une certaine
suffisance le mot est toujours
discutable mais voilà vers 1000 euros on
peut estimer qu'on a atteint le seuil de
pauvreté
et puis après on va de plus en plus vers
une émancipation de l'individu par
rapport à son patron par exemple pouvoir
négocier ses conditions de travail
jusqu'à quelquefois pouvoir refuser un
travail etc
pour y arriver des leviers de fiscalité
donc là je peux vous vers une heure
minimum sur la fiscalité est encore j'y
connais rien vous allez taper revenu de
base pour info pour compléter ce tedx
qui ne dure que 18 minutes à peu près
bref des fiscalités dans tous les sens
des taxes l'impôt sur revenu de la
cotisation il ya plein de recherche en
cours et qui vont varier dans wii de mon
temps entre 700 et 1000 500 euros on
peut avoir une réflexion aussi plus
générale pourquoi un revenu de base que
monétaire on peut le transformer en
service élargir les services publics les
biens communs au niveau local national
tout est possible tout est recherchée
aussi création monétaire souvent
méconnue alors nous avons le niveau
local
monnaie locale qui va adosser à l'euro
mais fructifier l'économie sociale et
solidaire d'un territoire
on a la monnaie nationale possible la
monnaie européenne alors est ce que vous
savez que la bce
notre banque centrale européenne crée 80
milliards d'euros à partir de rien
puisque c'est évidemment plus de l'or
tous les mois qu'elle distribue d'un
côté aux banques privées
de l'autre côté aux grandes entreprises
ça donne envie et banias un projet qui
disent tous et tout cet argent là on
pourrait le donner directement à chacun
et chacune chaque citoyen européen
pourrait avoir environ 150 euros par
mois et par citoyen et la havane où on
utiliserait comment l'utiliserai et dans
nos frais de tous les jours c'est à dire
dans l'économie réelle
une sacrée plus value pour l'économie
européenne et il ya les monnaies libres
qui elles sont sans frontières qui
existent déjà vous tapez sur internet
vous trouvez tout le dernier levier
n'est pas quantifiable mais on a quand
même quelques indices et vous
remarquerez la transition habile de la
speaker puisque je passe des économies
prévisible aux expérimentations qui nous
ont donné ces indices là alors par
exemple canada au canada ils ont fait
une expérience sur deux villes je vais
vous donner qu'un seul chiffre pour être
succincte et efficace huit et demi pour
cent en moins d'hospitalisations
ça fait rêver surtout en maladie
professionnelle en accident du travail
et tout ce qui est maladie psycho savez
quand on sait que les français sont
quand même les champions des
antidépresseurs il ya certainement un
filon d'économies par là j'enchaîne avec
les états unis qui ont fait plusieurs
expérimentations mais notamment quatre
dans les années 60 70 et or eux leur
angoisse c'est aimer son donne un revenu
de base est sûre plus personne n'ira
travail et donc ils ont compté les
heures de travail va figurer vous que si
les gens continuent à travailler
mazou pas j'en sais rien mais il ya que
deux catégories de personnes qui
travaillent sensible
- entre 10 et 30% les étudiants et les
jeunes mamans pas besoin de sous-titrés
pourquoi donc à priori c'était une super
expérimentation mais il ya eu un petit
dégât collatéral quelque chose de rien
du tout mais qui en a inquiété certains
c'est le nombre de divorces
oui on est dans les années 70 et les
dames n'avait pas d d'autonomie
financière à cette époque là et donc le
fait de recevoir le revenu de base ça
leur a fait regarder un peu différemment
leur relation conjugale
c'est malheureux à dire mais oui il y en
a certaines qui se sont dit ma relation
conjugale n'est que de la sécurité
financière
alors les conservateurs ont hurlé à
auront détruit la cellule familiale ont
détruit toute la société américaine sauf
que dans l'expérimentation qui a duré
onze ans le taux de mariage remonte donc
ça prouve bien que c'est pas un problème
avec le mariage mais par contre c'est
peut-être un bon indice d'émancipation
féminine dans le couple je pense qu'on
pourrait l'espérer encore aujourd'hui
mais aussi pourquoi pas l'élargir avec
l'employeur les femmes sont aujourd'hui
quand même celles qui subissent le plus
de temps partiel non choisi des
inégalités salariales etc
j'enchaîne avec l'expérimentation en
inde qui a été initiée par l'unicef et
un syndicat de travailleuses et or l'
extraordinaire
les résultats endettement / 3 scolarité
x 3 x 3 aussi d'activités économiques
des investissements sur la santé la
scolarisation des enfants le logement
surtout en termes sanitaires et les
outils de travail et avec tout ça
-14% anxiété vous demandez pas comment
ils ont testé ça le chiffre est
intéressant aussi
je termine avec un dernier exemple la
namibie pendant deux ans un village de
1000 habitants a reçu un revenu de base
je vous passe les effets qu'on a déjà vu
ailleurs scolarisation 92% meilleure
santé et ses activités économiques qui
explose il ya aussi un effet en plus ces
baisses de criminalité bah oui ça sert à
quoi d'aller tout casser de frauder
voler alors qu'on a ce qu'il nous faut
voilà donc ça c'est des effets qui sont
pas tous transférables mais qui sont
intéressants et alors dans cette
expérimentation à notre effet
intéressant c'est que figurez vous que
le front monétaire international est
intervenue la vérifier tous les chiffres
parce que cette expérience-là fallait
vérifier sa rentabilité il a dit non non
c'est pas possible
non c'est pas rentable du tout regardé
et les citoyens ces irréductibles
villageois se sont constitués en comité
et ont montré que le fmi pas de bol
s'était trompé dans ses chiffres
en fait c'était complètement rentable et
pas seulement financièrement mais en
termes humains aussi en coût humain
comme on dit et ils se sont avec leurs
petits comités leurs petits bras et
leurs petites jambes mais ils sont allés
voir tous les villages alentour et ils
ont comme ça sillonné toutes fans à midi
pour témoigner et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh ben le ministère est en
train de réfléchir très sérieusement à
une généralisation du revenu de base sur
tout le territoire
je vais pas pouvoir tout vous dire
revenu de base pour l'info en sortant
d'ici mais vous voyez qui en a partout
les expérimentations passé en cours et à
venir
je conclurai sur un petit point
intéressant que vous voyez à peu près au
milieu de l'europe et qui s'appelle la
france et oui il ya des projets en
france déjà au niveau d'un éco hameau
d'un département d'une région d'une
nation donc je conclurai là dessus le
revenu base est déjà là la question
maintenant c'est lequel lequel vous
ferai existait alors au boulot merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]